So today we're going to talk about the
benefits and the dangers of baking soda
which is sodium bicarbonate now I don't
know if you knew this but your body
actually makes baking soda okay it's
made by the pancreas and it's triggered
by a hormone in your small intestine
which gets signaled when the acid comes
through from the stomach and the stomach
you have this super super acidic mixture
between one and three and then it goes
into small intestine which should go up
to like maybe six or seven uh sometimes
even like 7.5 now if you know anything
about pH is this is like an extreme
difference of pH and so this is very
important for several reasons to have
these different PHS but the
neutralization of that stomach acid is
very very important which I want to
mention we don't neutralize the stomach
acid then we get a severe irritation and
inflammation in our small intestine but
it's that baking soda sodium bicarbonate
that's coming from the pancreas it's
going to help neutralize this acid now
why is this so important
well because the majority of the enzymes
that are needed for digestion
are activated they get turned on by a
much higher pH I mean if you think about
if you just look at the stomach
pepsin that's a very powerful protein
enzyme and that's activated by a pH
between like 1 to 1.5 so with that
enzyme you need a very strong stomach
acid but with the other enzymes right in
your small intestine coming out from the
pancreas you need a much higher more
alkaline pH for those enzymes to work
like trypsin for example which is a very
important enzyme with a pH of 7.5 to 8
and so this means that if you don't have
the bicarbonates to kind of buffer this
pH and we still have too much acidity
coming down in the small intestine that
enzyme trypsin cannot work it's useless
even lipase the lipid enzyme that comes
from the pancreas needs a pH of eight
and so I hope you can now see that the
vital importance of having the right pH
is in the right place are essential for
digestion especially when you talk about
enzymes and this is why you can't really
uh say that oh yeah the body is alkaline
or the body is to acid It's a
combination of a lot of different PHS
and so you need to understand this if
you're going to try to alkalize the body
or even acidify the body because as soon
as you start to alkalize the body like
with some remedy like even baking soda
it has to go through the stomach to get
to different places now bicarbonate is
not just produced by your pancreas it's
also produced by the little tubes that
connect
in between the liver and the gallbladder
the bile ducts actually secrete
bicarbonate as well which is interesting
let's say for example you have a problem
with your pancreas that you're not able
to produce enough enzymes which is not
very uh common because there's a huge
Reserve in your pancreas for these
enzymes but it definitely occurs and if
you have a deficiency the treatment is
taking enzymes but they rarely if ever
include bicarbonate with that so here
you are taking these enzymes but what is
going to activate it if you don't have
the right pH alkaline in your small
intestine because the pancreas for
example is too exhausted to release
these bicarbonates then what's going to
activate them
so in other words if you're going to
take enzymes I would also recommend you
take some baking soda with that
to help them get activated so from one
aspect baking soda might help your
digestion from just activating certain
enzymes now on another hand baking soda
may be helpful in certain situations
with like acid reflux or heartburn if
you don't take it very often and you
don't take it for a long period of time
because if you're going to take it for
you know weeks and months you're going
to actually create other problems
because usually the underlying cause of
heartburn or acid reflux is a lack of
acid not too much acid and so this is
why some of the side effects of
chronic consumption of baking soda can
create bloating gas and even something
called acid rebound where your body now
is going to make more acid to compensate
so if you wanted to take it short term
here and there for some acid reflux
that's fine
as long as you're also focused on
correcting that cause of it which is
usually a lack of acid this is why I
think a much better remedy would be
betaine hydrochloride and some apple
cider vinegar but let's say for example
you have an ulcer or let's say for
example you have gastritis okay
your stomach lining is just raw if you
take betaine hydrochloride or apple
cider vinegar you're just going to
irritate the heck out of it but you can
very easily take baking soda to give you
some relief so I just wanted to kind of
give you some specifics on like when you
may want to take it when you might not
take it now of course
there's going to be people commenting on
the channel that um say well you know my
grandfather took this his whole life and
he's you know 120 years old so it's fine
so I'm not here to tell you not to take
it because I I'm totally into natural
remedies but in flip side you always
want to ask yourself why do you need to
take any remedy at all and do you know
the cause I think you should find
natural remedies to kind of handle the
symptoms but also at the same time
really understand the mechanism so you
can really eventually get rid of the
cause which if you have heartburn really
relates to kind of what you're eating
all right another interesting benefit
has to do with increasing athletic
performance yeah having a little more
endurance because when you exercise
especially intense exercise you will
generate lactic acid okay so now we're
going to change the pH of certain
tissues in your body and so this lactic
acid tends to inhibit oxygen and then
what's going to happen is you're going
to hit the wall when you exercise so
you'll have a limited endurance but
there's been a few interesting studies
that shows that if you consume baking
soda 90 minutes before this exercise
intensity routine it can improve your
performance because it's going to
neutralize this acidity and then allow
more oxygen to occur but not only that I
think another thing that it does is that
baking soda turns into as a byproduct
water and CO2 carbon dioxide which
automatically allows oxygen to go into
the body if that's new information for
you you should watch my video on that
topic I'll put that down below but it's
fascinating now the CO2 connection
relates to this next benefit which
you know I found I had to dig deep but I
found some interesting research on the
relationship between picking sodium
bicarbonate and cancer and currently in
this one study that I'll put down below
there was a significant Improvement in
decreasing the incidence of metastasis
now this was in my studies but still
this is interesting data now why would
it do that well if you take a look at a
normal cell versus a cancer cell in
relationship to pH
the outside of a cancer cell
is way more acid than a normal cell let
the inside of that cell cancer cell is
alkaline more alkaline than a normal
cell
so that's interesting
so when people say that oh yeah cancer
is acid are you talking about the inside
of the cell or the outside of the cell
and there's a more concentrated amount
of lactic acid okay and lactate and that
can actually trigger the growth of
tumors so if you were to reduce that
kind of neutralize that pH
potentially you can actually prevent the
growth of the tumor now realize that all
this is kind of down chain in other
words it's like the kind of consequences
of this chain reaction that occurs
originally from some type of
damage to the mitochondria and then the
oxygen machine can't work and then the
body uses a different mechanism to get
its Fuel and then the body switches from
normal cell to now a cancer cell which
is kind of like a backup system to get
fuel and in the process there's a lot of
lactic acid generated and so when you're
taking baking soda you're not actually
doing anything for
this initial cause of cancer in the
mitochondria but but what I like about
it is that baking soda can increase CO2
and CO2 is all about allowing oxygen to
kind of go deeper into the tissues we're
taught that CO2 is just a waste product
but it's essential for oxygen so if
you're just like hyper focused on this
oxygen thing and you're ignoring CO2
it's not going to work so even if you do
searches on like CO2 carbon dioxide
in relationship to cancer there's some
therapies out there that shows that it
can inhibit the tumor growth just by
doing CO2 which is interesting which is
a byproduct of baking soda another uh
interesting thing about baking soda is
that people use it for their skin to
help decrease rashes or some type of
skin allergy also baking soda is good if
you have a sinus problem right if you
could just put it in a Neti Pot maybe a
fourth of a teaspoon with a little pinch
of sea salt and you dissolve that and
you get the vapors into your sinuses
that can greatly help your sinus
irritation so that would be more like a
sinus irrigation and one last
interesting benefit about using baking
soda and of course when I recommend it
I'm always talking about this taking it
sporadically not like all the time every
single day to help reduce the risk of
gout attacks because you can inhibit the
formation of that uric acid Crystal if
you just get your pH a little higher and
so you would want to monitor the pH in
your urine and take it until the pH of
your urine is like maybe a seven versus
like a five so anyway I just wanted to
give you more of an a different
Viewpoint of baking soda
um on maybe some potential benefits for
you but if you haven't seen this video
on baking soda which I talk about the
very unusual and surprising benefits you
should check it out I put it up right
here